your health your healing bells come back
enemies respond you get healed yeah it's
pretty much the second
and so it also acts as a save statement
for whatever gear system
okay exactly
i'll end up back there we do want to
also
kind of encourage rpg elements within
our rpg part of our game so
you will be able to interact with many
different npcs and characters
within our game and here we have danthia
is a
uh hunter which is one of the major
religions of our game and she's here
well to find a specific
character and she's basically asking us
like hey there's a
defender of her well that's stopping me
from progressing but since you're
you're a different faction you're a
remnant knight she probably won't attack
you
so if you can find this guy for me that
would be great
and so that that remnant knight faction
is that something that you join earlier
in the game or is that
yours like a starting class
that is actually kind of like a war
based uh
explanation of why your character can
you know uh
do certain abilities fight in certain
styles and have certain spell gems so
it's it's more
based versus class-based or anything
like that
uh so here we're going to actually make
the web we didn't have one
from the beginning so all these parts
that you see here
there's a bunch of different options and
uh
you can't when you have a full game you
won't be able to just
have it all you'll have to find
everything in the world make sure you
make sure you explore and find
everything that you you know so you can
have the full experience
but uh we're first going to pick the
weapon handle and this
changes your fighting style or your
animation set
um for example we have a glaze it's like
the dark ball
sort of thing i'm going to wield a
two-handed stabbing weapon which is a
spear
one-handed stabbing it's like a dagger
or like a fencing sword
um two-handed splashing is like a you
know a hammer or a great sword
um
so i already tried out the dual handles
so uh
and had some fun with it so uh let's try
something a little bit different so
let's do
let's do a bigger heavier weapon like a
hammer or a wall
some examples of that would be on a
chance on hate might poison an enemy you
have a correct bomb
for that uh another one would be when
you kill an enemy
your speed increases for 10 seconds and
so are these options available from the
beginning and they're just
kind of unavailable by forging costs or
are these things that you unlock as you
progress through the game
that's a great question so it's actually
uh most of these you're actually going
to go out the world and explore the
different milks and crannies
and pommels and weapon heads might drop
off of bosses or be found in certain
spots and levels
uh so it's more like you'll have kind of
really made set
basically this one these are called
codexes and this will change the way
your hammer looks like
uh some of them might look you know like
a normal warhammer and then there's
different themes like
there's an insect one so it's called
shari it'll look more like
insect like insect uh characters
something called
that's right yeah that's the morning
shirt okay do the
hammer whatever this is my personal
favorite
oh look at me yeah yeah and then we're
gonna upgrade to make it a little bit
stronger
and so there's two different currencies
that you were forging with what was a
diamond and one was a
kind of maybe an ingot looking one what
is the difference between those and
how do you go about acquiring them so
the ones that look like
diamonds are kind of uh there's a coke
and that's like the
main currency of the game and in the
final version it's not about working in
the demo for
frustration purposes uh it'll drop when
you die if you die again it'll
permanently be lost
and that's one of the main resources for
upgrading buying items
and all that stuff the other thing that
you're seeing the in-game booking
material that is the ore within the game
and the ore is a resource that's much
more limited so you're going to find
those at the level
um maybe certain enemies might drop them
but it's kind of your major limiting
factor for upgrading and crafting
gotcha wow that that was
very impressive how quickly you
dispatched them
definitely a lot more damage being dealt
with that than my dual wielding swords
that i was messing around with earlier
yeah yeah in the cradling system because
there's so much
customization we're pretty open the idea
of like
you can make really really powerful
combinations of weapons
and you can also make really really bad
ones too
so what did we see right there it was a
dash with a
kind of a fire trail left behind you and
it looked like that depleted the red bar
above the middle symbol yeah yeah that's
the uh
that's a fire scroll blade it was an
item that i picked up behind uh
and i equipped it while you guys were
talking um but basically
we have three of them right now
uh when you when you activate it you can
do
three things you can hit an enemy you
can dodge and you can block
and hitting an enemy will catch them on
fire fire dot
uh dodging does this uh firewall and
they're gonna
take damage and then if you block while
you're holding block
your stamina is going to drain the
enemies uh when they hit
it's going to cause your weapon to
explode
[Music]
okay yeah i did not have much luck
blocking earlier and so it was on my
list of things to ask about
i feel like the vlog was not blocking
nearly as long as i hoped
yeah you still take damage um and it
also has a parry built into it so
if you can block right at the right
moment you can parry them it'll stun the
enemy
and while they're stunned you'll be able
to do critical hit damage yeah something
that i thought was
kind of an interesting flourish is when
you go into your blocking animation
there is a there is a long wind-up to
the block it is in an
instantaneous shield up hammer up etc
uh just like a it's almost like an
attack but
you're pulling your block out it's a bit
different than a lot of action use
yeah it's very difficult timing um it's
actually something we're in the
process of uh just kind of fine tuning
right now
some of them are a lot easier like if
you use dagger heads they have an
increased block window and they're much
faster
uh and so there's even perks to like
upgrade up uh pairings make it even
more easy um and so i just uh
interviewed
this is alera she's the defender i was
uh mentioning earlier the guardian of
farewell
and she's getting us a warning of like
hey you can traverse the gardens for a
while
we're gonna touch uh and she's probably
not gonna like that so
we'll see if we see her later on
and so i guess if you do a bloodless
run through this like i assume that you
can just
you know it's kind of speed run through
and dash will that mean that you won't
have an encounter with her later on
uh i guess does that layer is that level
of player choice available or is it a
no matter what you're going to be
defiling the ground so i will say
more specifically for her unfortunately
like you will have the fighter she is uh
she kind of plays further role in the
story and you do get to explore so you
don't just straight up
kill her but you will have to fight her
unfortunately but that like what you
said like of
completely avoiding people and kind of
changing outcomes is something we have
plans for like you really want to like
play our option to like so down there
there's another character although at
that game he's the one that locked this
out
yeah choose to kind of get um vengeance
from
setting up an ambush for you or you can
save and bring them back to the town and
maybe that'll open up another quest for
different awards
uh and even the process of like seeing
over and completely not interacting with
them
or maybe the all these enemies that he's
trying to use just paid for maybe he'll
get him instead
uh and so we do want to have like all
manners of like different choices and
hopefully people play through and see
how these different outcomes affect
things in different ways
yeah i'm a big fan of from software's
games i've played all of them
um so that's a very a very demon souls
kind of vibe
to it um that i appreciate that
it's definitely a bit harder for our
team size but like our
writer henry has he absolutely loves
that kind of thing too and so he's
trying to include it in every way
he can and so how big is your team
uh well for the majority of our games
i'd say like the first
four years it's been about uh six of us
and i think eric if you want to correct
me we're at
12 12
they said how has the pandemic affected
the development cycle uh
uh unfortunately for us uh before the
pandemic uh
hit back in 2018 we relocated and
started working remotely exclusively
so when the pandemic happened it didn't
really change much for us
as a team maybe perhaps for our
individual
second home not having to feel like kind
of a question
creativity a little bit but it didn't
so we had a little bit of practice and
we all the different kings that kind of
comes out
you know working remotely
to be in a process where i think fits
for our
studio um so we just
accepted a quest for craig's cognac
which uh
i'm looking forward to webster's whiskey
later on
so so tell me a little about the quest
system and how
do you have a quest log is it something
that's a little more inscrutable like it
dark souls or is it more like a
traditional oh there we go more of a
tradition
so there is a mix like not all the
information will be completely open to
player like some things will be a bit
more secretive
but we do have a lot more quests and we
do want you to have a general idea of
where to go and how to do certain things
and so we do have this quest and so um
instead of recipe does that imply
there's a crafting system for items
outside of weapons
uh so uh the cracks cognac so there's uh
the recipes for brews is what we call
them
uh brews are a consumable resource that
gives you a really powerful bonus and
a really bad negative as well so it's
kind of like this
what that does is it increases your
damage by 25
but you lose 25 percent of your max
health gotcha but like let's say
wow we really like this we want more we
found the recipe for it so if we go back
to town
we can go to the tavern and uh get more
crafted we can purchase
basically an infinite home okay and so
is the town is there a single town
that's a hub world that you are
branching out from
or are there multiple towns that you are
traversing
through the environment with uh there's
only
one like kind of major civilization left
in my major i mean
it's not much it's like kind of a sad
settlement
but that's called uh stars fire and it's
actually where you start out in the game
so from starspire you'll uh do a small
question and you'll unlock the grain
wave which is that what you saw in the
trailer that
sand ship that lets you travel across
this ruin of sand
and as soon as you leave the starspire
whatever you see as long as you're not
blocked by any kind of objects
and you find a doctor like that you can
go to so like
as soon as you launch they'll be pretty
much like eight islands that you can
choose to go to and some might be pretty
hard but if you're skilled enough you
can tell me land and start clearing it
out
so and you can go to any of those in any
order just
your mileage may vary with how far you
get exactly
so for example here is one of the four
kind of
major starter islands that you can
choose from and uh to give you kind of
an example
i like all the the verticality is really
impressive um the you kind of see how
the level loops back
on itself over stacking over on top of
each other
um because now we're on top of that gate
that we saw that we were trapped outside
of early
um and the isometric perspective you use
it very well
to kind of hide the fact that you will
be going above where you are now
and then it's almost like it's a reveal
later on that you're in the same
location
yeah and we actually want to use it the
opposite way too for other
islands so like an island that will
start at the top
work your way down
i don't know why i i think a lot of
people and especially myself that's why
we aimed for it
but verticality just it feels better it
feels better than that like kind of
flatter
uh top-down feel um it's one of the
things like we hope
helps stand out for our game like a lot
of people might be coming in here
thinking it's not a hack and slash
diablo game
when it's a lot closer to just that pop
down diabolo style where you're being
careful with the encounters where you're
thinking of
your route to a level and all that yeah
i was to ask about that so
the loot system um is it's you have a
singular piece of armor that you're then
upgrading i see you have a
pretty nifty hat there now um yeah
so it looks like like will i guess is it
a traditional kind of loot game where
you can run through islands multiple
times
to get better drops of loot or is it you
are
unlocking specific bits as you go so
this is the one hat
that you have this is the lucatiel hat
from dark souls 2.
yeah i'm glad you asked that question so
that's exactly the case
so with the weapon crafting the other
thing we have on top of that is the
armor system
and like like you're asking it is that
one piece of armor is from one place
always in the game and you can only find
it in that location
and maybe it's maybe it's a drop on the
ground or it's from a specific elite mob
or a boss
but it will always just be there and
these armor pieces
have set effects and they're static so
uh right now
you'll do uh a certain amount of damage
for a certain amount of time so that was
like really good for clearing a level
but maybe not so good for bosses
okay and so looking over on the on the
left hand side and there's the hats the
kind of the body armor legs gloves
and then the weapon slot but there's it
looks like there's at least
yeah there's four other positions that
have nothing in them
one is i assume is for dual hit for like
an offhand is there something else that
goes in the
other the top left top right and bottom
right positions
if that's a square right now it actually
is
but there is going to be a bit something
like a trinket system
which is um if you played hollow knight
it's not too different
so for example if i feel like my camera
right now is too heavy
i can pick this haste room and the haste
room will actually increase my attack
speed
so i'll just put them in my armor and
further increase my attack speed
but right now my armor only has one slot
it'll start unlocking more uh sockets so
i can
find even more haste runes and just keep
adding more history to make myself as
fast as possible
and so how do you balance out people who
want to experiment with
different armor sets but i've already
you know spent
five thousand gems and ten ingots
upgrading this one armor sets
even if i like is there a translog style
system or do you have to start back at
level one for every new piece of armor
you get
so you it is a little punishing in that
way that you would have to start over
from level one
but let's say like if you do spend like
ten thousands quite a bit so you'll be
up in the world
and we're dropping enough resources
enough items that you'd be able to
pretty quickly uh not have just the one
set you can have multiple sets
and also very quickly have a completely
new set if you choose to do so
maybe you won't be as strong as the one
you've been rolling with but you'll be
able to at least get it like
two competitive levels fairly quickly
okay
we are coming up close to the end of our
interview but i did want to show one
last thing
um about the character customization
um we have a blessing system which is
basically like a talent tree
and this first row is like the basic
things that increase damage increase
armor
and prop chances if i want to increase
the amount of times my spawn ally will
work
this is the one i'm going to want to
pick further down the line you have
different you can increase your damage
in uh two specific weapons um so say we
really love the weapon that we're using
i would put more points to that to
increase the damage
and uh yeah are these blessings just
something that this that
uh danathia can give you or are they
fashion specific
or uh they're they're kind of uh
something that you go
to the monk hub uh it's just for the
demo that we have everything like
including the forge and all that stuff
here at this specific level
normally you want to go back to the hub
level and upgrade your character there
uh and that's where that will always be
got it
um the open world aspects where you're
sailing in between uh levels on that
ship across the deserts
um is there are there things that can
hap are there encounters that happen in
that open world area or are they
just is it just flavor to movie from one
spot to the next
uh currently it's in the design that
it's a bit of flavor and kind of think
of it as a
deep breath for the player where there's
not anything challenging is your way
where you can kind of just take a moment
to collect yourself as you go from
island island
and slowly explore um we do have a lot
of
design plans on like storms or like
us things that can like muddle your your
journey or kind of disorient you or
maybe like
sand pits or things to kind of explore
the ocean like
treasure maps of finding treasure within
the sand um but
in its current iteration uh we don't
have anything more than
kind of just slowly perusing and
exploring and taking it all in yeah kind
of a wind waker
exactly yeah so is this the
is this the gentleman that uh you have
the quest
to go after no he's actually uh
somewhere else
some level and if you do take a time to
try it for yourself we hope you
kind of check it out and try to finish
that quest this is lady alera the one
that we saw earlier giving us the
morning
stuff
cassidy is making very quick yeah
that hammer is devastating yeah the
hammer is really good i died so many
times
he made them look way too easy to say
i'm glad that uh we picked a good weapon
for you to take her out
and i will say that there's something
about the weapon suit that encourages
you to kind of play with different
those twos and i from my experience just
kind of playing through different bosses
is that
certain weapon combinations work really
well for that particular right like for
her
there's moments where you can kind of
catch her where she's gonna throw her
animations
but you can really devastate her with a
big head
but then there's also ones that are like
much faster
and they recover quicker
well i guess my last question is just if
you want to
if people want to know what yeah this is
where i went
to start off the demo when i first got
it with no weapon i was just like this
is
just terrible um
for people who have not heard of the
game before and like me see the trailer
and they're kind of struck by
by the art style what's what do you want
them to
know about this game if nothing else
oh gosh that's a great question yeah
i would want them to know that it's not
just another souls quote
that we're really trying to play with in
that
genre but we're trying to stay outside
of it at the same time
yes i i think on top of that would be
like
you're not gonna experience something
like you might come into thinking it's
an action
slash game and it might frost frustrate
players a bit
but if they learn the mechanics they
understand the systems i think they're
gonna have a really fun
time and finding that this is a
different experience from anything
before awesome well this has been great
thank you guys so much for your time and
i'll let you move on to your next
appointment but i really enjoyed this
and like i said i tried to demo out
earlier and
i'll definitely be messing with it a
little bit more that now that uh
now that i know not to go not to turn
right immediately
thank you so much thank you yeah feel
free to contact us
if you have any other questions
absolutely when uh how far along are we
and how close are we to release
uh so uh we are applying for early
access uh we plan for early access to be
somewhere in
uh q4 this show or q1 of that sure okay
npc only
for now yes uh would be
happy if we ever have the opportunity
for other points as well
yeah i'm looking at this and licking my
chops without it being honest on the
switch so
great uh well thank you so much for your
time and uh enjoy the rest of
you guys